[Music]
in forced piercing news oh let me do
that I just thought about nipple
piercings funny stuff cuz who wouldn't
want to do is need ya know I said if I
said who wouldn't want to do it who
would want it I heard wouldn't either
no Mike did I say that would not like to
do it no we wouldn't want to do is I
have a girlfriend Marissa recently did
it and I'm like are you kidding
some people don't have feeling there I
have a lot of feelings I can't even look
at it all day or play with it like you
know it's just like a kink thing yeah
it's like a tug on it thing you know you
can attach things to it I guess I was
actually considering getting a bar that
just goes from one nipple do pull-ups on
any chip
this is submitted by Roger wet it why no
way BAE this is very that makes sense
for this so I children's retailer
Claire's y'all over is it yes another
body part about this after an
ex-employee exposes questionable
ear-piercing policies what are you man
hmm eclairs is a children's place like a
peer sit on a like dummy like a dummy
mannequin thing and they a lot of times
they just have an hour long training and
they don't they don't know they aren't
like yeah if there aren't like an hour
long I mean it's not rocket science
right you just get that [ __ ] gun long
potentially yeah I have three holes and
I did these to my with the ice do you
how old were you get in I was like 13
did you do in the girls bathroom at
school champ no I did it at home I had
this weird thing for pain at that time I
don't know I pierced my own nose well
[ __ ]
but you liked it I liked it I really
love that I love that pop and I'm like
[ __ ] if I could I just do the whole
thing but then I was like no I gotta
calm down it's not good to do it with a
gun either like they do at Claire's
because it's yeah they do it with the
gun but just like the piercing you
should do with a needle like it's a
two-shot because one it's more hygienic
and two it doesn't like like disrupt
your skin when you do it they're kind of
girls like this and then like your
skin's all [ __ ] frayed and yeah with
a needle it's like a pure hole I had
four on my car and they all got infected
and I left it there for so long because
I was a
disgusting my nose got infected it was
so nasty I didn't even know it got
infected but like the little like a bolt
like a ball of skin just yeah for me and
it was like starting to cover my nose
ring I forgot which side cuz I did both
sides dude I don't get the nose thing
like I'm like be like I said every time
no the one on I like on this side I'm
always like this just looks they don't
like this you know um to pocket it it's
okay oh yeah ugh have it how can you
pick your nose yeah how do you think you
know my favorite pastimes is to pick my
nose and I don't get that
it's infringing on my rights that's true
when I had it and I got back from Mexico
um the the customs officer he was like
you just got back from Mexico are you
sure with an India I'm like the bindi
what are you trying to be funny I don't
know I think he was like I don't know
he's like are you sure you know where
you're coming from man exactly because
you know what you look like right that
nose ring right he's one of those like
patronizing Oh like don't trying to make
the teenager feel like you're stupid
we're doing yeah yeah one of those I
like septum piercings like about one
yeah I think those are cool I think
those are gonna be cool looking like a
cow yeah but if it's small enough it
doesn't look that couch why is it a cow
thing because they put that in there
bolt in the bulls why they can pull on
it yeah I heard so they have to go
because they have to live in pain yeah
like tie the big tie like the balls for
the bull rodeo for the rodeo things so
it's not [ __ ] around one there
everybody know it makes him angry
oh so then they're like oh crazy yeah
cuz we're like get this [ __ ] thing
off my balls yeah rodeos like they're a
major bummer
yeah they are yeah I want to go to one
do not support I never been to a rodeo
before yeah I think they always have
them stole you've been in LA we got seen
these clay I look up concert tickets
sometimes and I see them I like sad
shows but they kill the ball bro do they
at the NI thing do we get to eat it
after happy says oh it's a guy bull it's
a guy ball okay gobbles I'm not a cat
not a cow oh really
I don't know anything about it [ __ ]
know anything you don't look at me
[ __ ] yeah there you go anyway we're
talking about Claire's here yes which is
a retailer geared at young girls and
teens and so this ex-employee said that
there was this seven year old girl that
came in with her mom and she was barely
very clearly like just not wanting to
get her ears pierced and then the mom
was like trying to convince her like the
daughter and then eventually the mom
agreed like okay fine let's not do this
let's go home so then the employee was
curious about like how far do these like
policies go like and so she ended up
going up to her manager and asked like
hey if the mother insisted in like the
little girl was screaming kicking
screaming like just not wanting it but
the mom like held her down and said do
it am i obligated to do this and the
manager said yeah you have no choice but
to do it what a child tell soup Italian
children all your property until they're
18 that's what I think oh so then that's
what sparked a lot of backlash to Claire
saying like well what does this teach
like this teaches a child that they're
refusing consent can be to be touched
means nothing and so yeah but what about
[ __ ] doctors and if if I want my
[ __ ] daughter or son have pretty eyes
earrings or get pretty ass earrings hey
my daughter doesn't consent to getting
this vaccinations off [ __ ] yeah well
they're saying that if it if it's
something that's for they're helping
further but like this is only a that is
this cosmetic yeah so that's they're
acting like they're putting a plate on
the lip a plate on the lip yeah and like
you know how some travel day yeah like
something insane
it's a piercing that's not what hurts a
little bit and it goes away yeah come on
oh yeah doesn't always go away I got I
got this [ __ ] right here with the gun
and there's a hole here my ear hurts
sometimes it rings yeah
I don't think that's more than just a
piercing no way I've been happened since
then like when I get a loud clap
sometimes or like a fork you know it
just goes this is what leads to like
babies like who have diapers are not
getting a giving consent when you change
it I miss you yes a it just gets too far
sometimes where people rope consent into
random [ __ ] I'm like wait this is like a
different thing like this is a mom with
her kid and yeah it's like really dumb
of the mom to make their kid do that
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] wrong but some
moms do it when the babies are born and
the babies have no consent you know
wanted to do and I said no yeah because
I feel bad yeah yeah they just do it
early so then when they grow up they
don't have to deal with the pain yeah
yeah I'm kind of I wish you would have
waited and had a professional to do it
because they're wrong they're all good
like we get same with the other two that
I did myself that's true cuz when you
become an adult your ears grow and stuff
so you might as well do it like that cuz
if you're a baby it might be like you
know I actually want Leah to fill the
pain that's why well watch cuz I want
her to be like you know what this sort
of feels like I want you to do when
you're ready to and that's what she
doesn't go and get other piercings and
other places no that's what my mom
wanted me one of those he's gonna be
daddy's eyes her shotgun a beer so he's
like that's what it feels like you had
yourself piercings and you're just like
she can't have piercings in heaven no no
she can't she needs to make the
decisions yeah I want her to be able to
feel the pain herself so she's like oh
and like me oh I love this [ __ ] and
they're just that piercing everything
you're so then your sad father after
that because your daughter Laurie she
has to be 18 to do it on her own
no there could be 15 or 16 with written
notice yeah oh yeah but like you deaf
not in Mexico I did - excuse my
bellybutton when I was 13 we talked
about go to Mexico all the time I was 15
that's tight well I do my tongue to my
own other piercings you think yeah I've
never heard like guys getting their
tongue Spears in my eyebrow too good I
think this is back in their days and
people liked it though like yeah what's
the rating time yeah yeah I wanted
everyone had their tongue pierced
well that's because if if a guy is his
tongue pierced he can suck it better
that's what I heard
the ravers would get their
glow-in-the-dark like tongue piercings
and then they would like to take a
second a dark dude I used to think that
[ __ ] when I was in like middle school
and [ __ ] when the girl had the piercing
I was like awesome I suck dick so good
that's where it came from though yeah
the guys with their own piercings down
there the Prince Albert oh really it
came from yet it's all yeah when guys
get their dicks piercing like wow well
you know our [ __ ] metal dude I'd be
too paranoid about that
what if it gets stuck in me what if it
gets infected you lose your dick dude I
mean curious though it's afraid that's a
[ __ ] free theme [ __ ] I heard I don't
it's very yeah I heard something I'll
know his truth that in prison they put a
little bit they do that ball into the
peanut group yeah they put they put
marbles in there yeah we relieved a ball
from why do they do where they got the
ball from but they do cut through and
insert like a ball there because well
then when they get out they can please
the woman better that had like the whole
like it was just all like yeah does it
make them feel better
no it's because it's because they want
to [ __ ] like lay it down so also they
probably do it to the people they're
terrorizing in jail then no it's because
when they get out and then they can get
they just want the girl to just like
cream crazy Oh what are you doing metal
balls okay
inside of the theme so it's like you
know like that you know okay yeah some
cultures have in the be hall no it's
like end of the skin
oh I see there's like a mutant between
the mushroom and the forest dude the
chicks not gonna like this [ __ ] we're
talking about work system yeah that's
what they think they can hit the g-spot
and not be done for that one
that's what jerking off in prison all
day does to you you're like oh [ __ ] so
love if I have a club [ __ ] bubble
dick this is the other thing true where
they'll get a guy and then they'll cut
his armpits little [ __ ] aren't fit
because it's [ __ ] tight it's like a
tight virgin [ __ ]
so they'll slit it and the guy will [ __ ]
it you know and are you watching some
[ __ ] up animation noise [ __ ] dude I
don't know hey why can't you just
[ __ ] go in between yeah yeah why
can't you just hold it really tight
is this their part in there for lunch
how you buy your armpit there it's a
fart pass and can't come and watch why
is it going to the armpit then just cut
a hole anywhere then I don't know about
that alright cos it's a Titus cuz it
opens and closes I don't know because it
goes the deepest
there's no bone right there your armpit
I'm not doing it I don't like that I
don't consent underneath it
oh my god no this video is over sweat to
come out I'm going to JK party it's way
lighter there
[Music]
[Music]